the occupation of a wildlife refuge by
an Oregon militia is now entering its
third week last week and this is real
I'm not making it up a member of the
group when I'm Facebook to complain
about the number of sex toys that are
being mailed to the group yeah people
are sending them sex toys as like a joke
and they're getting mad the militia has
asked supporters to send things like
socks cigarettes and energy drinks
instead well here's the video that this
guy put on so we went and picked up some
mail that came in they spend and waste
their money on all this cable stuff to
send out your trust and buy this
ridiculous it's it's really ridiculous
she's in a bag of dicks
[Music]
yeah well clearly clearly that guy's
upset so I set up a satellite link with
members of the Oregon militia to talk
about it please welcome live by a
satellite
Jake met her Nick let's talk to him find
out what's going on hey Jake so people
have been sending you adult toys it's
cool it just a prank why are you so
upset because it's disrespectful
we asked for food and clothes and we got
87 dildos and 58 vibrators all right
clearly more than one needs yes I
understand a lot three for every guy
here yeah
we're not all into peas I like those
vibrating eggs
all right listen knowing no one asked
you about that okay okay look American
people we are cold and hungry
please stop sending us plastic and
rubber penises send us clothes like
sturdy boots leather chaps and zippered
masks send us some food all right like
some edible panties or chocolate syrup
or whipped cream maybe one of those
erotic cakes shaped like a Wang you see
a bachelorette party yeah we got it
we understand just say erotic cake it's
fine if you do send Lube make it
flavored lube we're not animals and a
vibrating egg I don't want to hear about
the vibrating egg there's four pounds
available on Amazon I prefer the space
invader bye love Co here's a link all
right no one wants to see your
if we sold out of that one give me the
Golden Goose it has remote control
no one cares Jake better Nick of the
Oregon militia I don't care about the
egg
[Applause]
is a good product hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy japanese pornography